tu serais Mme Dutton, il semblerait que nous soyons
voisins, j'ai acquis le ranch de Stratford,
eh bien, c'est la pierre jaune et vous
n'avez aucun droit ici
Jacob, vous ne pouvez pas démarrer une gamme. Gamme de guerre Les
guerres ont déjà commencé,
atterrissons, voulez-vous
Je veux que toute la vallée,
peut-être que nous leur livrions ce combat ou que ça
arrive, nous,
les hommes, tuons vite avec une balle pour un nœud coulant,
leur combat est avec moi et je tue
beaucoup plus lentement,
tu es un chasseur, tu es célèbre,
dis au monde ce qui se passe.  quand ils
me croiseront, la
cupidité sera la chose qui nous tuera
tous.
L'eau de pluie
vient avec moi,
tu sais, Dieu, Jacob ne le fait pas.
[Applaudissements]
tu attaques ma famille, ce sera la
dernière chose que tu feras.